لقد قمنا أيضًا ببناء شراكة
لإنتاج لقاح في خمسة
بلدان ولدينا الآن قدرة إنتاج تصل إلى
500 مليون
لقاح يمكن إنتاجها في
الأشهر الـ 12 المقبلة ،
لذا فإن هذا مهم جدًا لأننا لن
ننتج لقاحًا في روسيا فقط سننتج
لقاح مع
دول أخرى في شراكة حقيقية
وإتاحة اللقاح حقًا
للعالم للدول التي تريد البلدان
التي تحتاج
إليه ونتوقع أن تبدأ التجارب السريرية
في الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
المملكة العربية السعودية ، الفلبين قريبًا جدًا ،
ربما تلاحظ تعليقًا من
رئيس الفلبين يريده  للمشاركة أيضًا
في تلك التجارب السريرية ،
ولكن سيتم إجراء التجارب السريرية في
دول مختلفة حول العالم
عندما وافقت روسيا للتو على ما
تقول إنه أول لقاح لفيروس كورونا في العالم على
الرغم من المخاوف
بشأن سلامته وفعاليته في
مؤتمر عبر الفيديو مع كبار المسؤولين
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
أعلن بوتين أن اللقاح الروسي الصنع قد
خضع
لجميع الاختبارات اللازمة ولم يكن كذلك  w
مسجّل للاستخدام
على الرغم من أن
التجارب البشرية في المرحلة الثالثة الحاسمة لم تكتمل بعد
، أكد وزير الصحة الروسي
أن العاملين الصحيين
والمعلمين في الخطوط الأمامية سيكونون أول من يتم
تطعيمهم.كشف فلاديمير بوتين أيضًا
بشكل لا يصدق عن إحدى بناته الذين
نادرًا ما نسمعهم  حول
أنها شاركت في الاختبار
وتم تطعيمها بالفعل ، قال
إنها أصيبت
بارتفاع طفيف في درجة الحرارة لكنها الآن
تشعر بتحسن ، إنه كشف غير عادي
وعلامة على مدى
الثقة التي
تتمتع بها روسيا عن حق أو خطأ في ما يقوله وزير الصحة.
هو مساهمة كبيرة
في الانتصار على فيروس كورونا